SORRY FOR THE HATE SPEECH.
AS LONG AS YOU REPENT IT'S OKAY.
CANDACE OWENS IS UP THEY CANDAC
OWENS PODCAST RATE IT IS GREAT
TO SEE YOU TONIGHT, THANK YOU
FOR COMING ON.
BOTH OF US OF COURSE WENT FOR
STANFORD, WE MET IN THE COMPUTE
SCIENCE DEPARTMENT FOR US THIS
IS PERSONAL.
WHAT WOULD YOU SUGGEST THEY BE
ON?
>> I'VE GOT TO BE HONEST, I'M
SCARED TO SPEAK, I'M NOT TRYING
TO GET BANNED, I'M TRYING TO
ABIDE BY ALL THE RULES WHICH
WOULD PROBABLY BE EASIER IF
YOU'RE A STUDENT AT STANFORD IF
YOU JUST KEPT HER MOUTH SHUT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A WALKING
MINEFIELD.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE IN SOME
MORE WORDS, I WOULD SAY WE
SHOULD BE ON INTELLIGENCE,
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE IT'S THE
EVILEST TERM, THEY HAVE A WHOLE
SEXUAL AND FOR ABLE IS IMPAIRED
IT DOESN'T ALLOW PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE THINKING BRAINS TO
JOIN IMPAIRED PEOPLE CREELEY WH
CREATED THIS LIST DON'T HAVE
THINKING BRAINS.
WHEN PEOPLE SEE THINGS LIKE THI
IS THAT COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE
BECOME A CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE.
KIDS ARE TAKING HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN LOANS T
ATTEND THESE UNIVERSITIES TO BE
TOLD ESSENTIALLY THAT THEY CAN
SPEAK AND EVERYTHING THEY DO AS
WRONG.
I'M NOT SURE AT WHAT BENEFIT IT
IS FOR PARENTS TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO UNIVERSITY ANYMORE
WHEN THEY COME BACK IN DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR OWN
GENDER STRAIGHT THEY COME BACK
DUMBER THAN WHAT YOU SENT THEM
BECAUSE THEY SEE EVERYTHING AS
BUZZWORD EVERYTHING IS A TRIGGER
, AND IN THE END THEY END
UP WITH NONPRODUCTIVE HUMAN
BEINGS AND SOCIETY THAT ALSO
HAVE HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND NOTHING
THAT THEY CAN DO BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTS TO HIRE THESE PEOPLE,
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE SENSITIVE
CRYBABIES AND END UP BECOMING
GOVERNMENT DEPENDENCE, ANGRY
PROFESSORS THEY GO BACK INTO TH
ECOSYSTEM THAT TAUGHT THEM THE
NONSENSE AND THE FIRST PLACE.
THIS IS SO LAUGHABLE, BUT YOU
SHOULDN'T LAUGH BECAUSE THIS IS
COMING FROM STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
STANFORD, HARVARD, YELL, ALL
THESE PRETENTIOUS UNIVERSITIES,
THE BEST, THE SMARTEST, THE
CREAM OF THE CROP, I'M SURE
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY THAT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY COME UP WITH.
ASTOUNDING, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IS A COVER FOR THEM
, YOU CAN'T USE THE TERM
BEAT A DEAD HORSE, IS SOMEBODY
THAT LOVES ANIMALS I WOULD BE
EXCITED TO KNOW HOW MANY DOGS,
CATS, AND MONKEYS HAVE BEEN
TORTURED OVER THE YEARS AT
STANFORD BECAUSE THEY GOT SOME
GOVERNMENT GRANT TO DO IT, NOT
TO ADVANCE SCIENCE BUT BECAUSE
THEY GOT PAID TO TORTURE THOSE
ANIMALS TO DEATH.
YOU THINK THEY WILL ANSWER THAT
QUESTION?
>> THAT WOULD BE AGAINST THE
RELIGION OF HOW SHE IS HIM AND
YOU WANT TO BE VERY CAREFUL NOT
TO BE ANTI- FAUCI ANYWHERE
BECAUSE GOD FORBID YOU ANY OF
HIS EXPERIMENTS THAT THEY'VE
DONE ON ANIMALS, YOU WILL LAND
YOURSELF ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY, I WOULDN'T
DARE SPEAK AGAIN